one of the best things that could happen
for the left is for the right to do
damage to Itself by just getting
involved in complete and total nonsense
when I hear complete and total nonsense
one of the first names that comes to
mind is Mike Lindell pillow the CEO and
founder of MyPillow who's been a guest
on this program multiple times don't
miss my last interview with him it was
pretty whacked Mike pillow is officially
launching his campaign for Republican
party chairman he is targeting Ronald
McDaniel he says Rhonda McDaniel is
leading the party in the wrong direction
and part of his evidence of that is that
the election from a few weeks ago should
have been a massive Red Wave and it
wasn't and here is Mike pillow making it
clear he's really doing this take a
listen it should have been the biggest
red wave in the history of the world
right ever
[Music]
um and you know and it didn't happen and
why didn't it happen
um well the donors want to know we put
in all the money come on what what
happened well you better find out what
happened the the RNC completely lied to
the American people they enter their
donors and said that they would go after
election Integrity they called it
Integrity I call it election crime oh
yeah we're out for election Integrity
really what have you done what did you
do in 2020 You Know What You Did in 2020
but the RNC did everybody is they all
got together and here's a fact and said
oh we're not going to do anything
because we could get sued that would be
one of their excuses we could get sued
by the machine companies
well let's just let our country be
destroyed and let's just keep taking
money for our donor Can it can you
imagine if this guy was the chairman of
the Republican National Committee oh my
goodness and we hope that we can
override the algorithms
yeah we should we should encourage this
we should support this wholeheartedly
even if pillow doesn't win it would be a
very nice distraction for the Republican
party so maybe they don't do as many
damaging things and just on the off
chance that pillow wins it would wreak
total havoc on the 2024 primary it would
bring in a massively pro-trump RNC chair
which is the exact opposite of what the
establishment Republican party wants to
see at this point in time the left
should 100 percent be supporting this
and no I still haven't gotten those free
pillows from Mike pillow at this point I
don't even really know that I want them
so uh to to take kind of a more thirty
thousand foot View
of the RNC and the Republican Party
thinking about 2024. what the Republican
Party absent even the pillow stuff is
going to have to figure out for 2024.
is do they go fully against Trump
but if they do that the risk is Trump
wins the nomination and then what
happens or do they just remain sort of
neutral publicly behind the scenes try
to work against Trump so that if indeed
Trump is the 2024 Republican nominee
there's still some sort of plausible
deniability or ability to work with
Trump and to try to get them to do some
things that they would like to see him
do I quite frankly can't imagine what a
2024 Trump presidency would be or
starting in 2025 if Donald Trump were to
win because he seems completely
uninterested in actual governance that
there's not even a pretense of policy
other than these vague things well we're
going to shut down the border crossings
again even though nothing really changed
since he left and bite it it's not
really policy he's not even pretending
that he's going to get us that beautiful
health care plan anymore so I don't know
what such a presidency looks like and
the RNC would probably be well advised
if they think there's any shot that
Trump has at this thing which clearly
Trump has some shot how do they stay
enough in his good graces that they can
actually get him to achieve some policy
things or or even pay attention to them
that's the real question I don't know
which direction they'll go in